searching for the missing today they
came in speedboats
Navy army and police with one goal to
find British backpacker Amelia bambridge
in teams they scour the waters around
the Cambodian island of koh rong
desperate for a breakthrough up ahead
the military are talking to fishermen
about a possible lead we pull up
alongside have you found anything in
your net please shout across they draw a
blank
the crew say they haven't
but the fisherman's eyes are vital as
authorities search a huge area of land
and sea but with every passing day the
danger to Amelia grows large parts of
this island are totally uninhabited and
you can see just how inhospitable the
terrain is thick jungle there leading
down to a rocky coastline and into the
sea yet officials are still hoping
somewhere out there they'll find Amelia
Amelia had traveled to the Cambodian
island as part of her holiday to
Southeast Asia she disappeared after a
beach party last Thursday the number of
officials looking for her is rising
today a hundred and forty-seven join the
search but there's still no sign of the
21 year old I'm not sure what happened
to the missing girl maybe she went for a
swim and drowned or got lost in the
jungle or maybe she was murdered we are
trying to do everything we can to find
her walls on this holiday Island are
plastered with posters appealing for
information police are now questioning
six men as witnesses the tourists coming
here it's unnerving coming to the island
it feels very safe here but seeing the
posters when I got off the boat and
clean the news articles made me feel
quite unsettled and like I should be a
bit more cautious about where I go and
just have my wits about me slightly more
than I usually would tonight the police
returned to the spot where amelia was
last seen the place where she simply
vanished
and six days on they're no closer to
finding her shamone ovens Sky News Quran
Cambodia